please welcome the wonderful ellie
kemper
hello hi
how are you i'm so good
how are you i am so happy to be here and
to see your face and i just want to
thank you
for bringing everyone so much joy on
these very hard hard days thank you
thank you i take that from you as the
ultimate compliment
um because i mean for so many years
you have been this beacon of
joy and comedy and that's something that
was like
the thing that you know how can we all
be ourselves
you know we can only really we can't
fake it we can't pretend to be other
people
it's like for better or worse we offer
ourselves into the world
and you have been someone who is
beautiful
funny charming whimsical
you know highly recognized and
acknowledged and awarded for it and that
to me
is really doing a huge service to people
not only are you exercising your
artistic
you know endeavors but it's like you say
ellie kemper and people are like oh my
gosh
i mean you're just i am going to take
what you just said i'm going to
record it and play it on a tape every
morning when i get out of bed i'm going
to be like drew barrymore said that
i will uh put it in a voice memo and
just send it to you until you're like
thank you i got it enough um everything
back to you that's that what you just
said applies to you a hundred fold so
thank you for saying that
i have like such deep respect for you
that it's just
amazing to hear you say that because i
know you know
so thank you and um
you know it's funny to hang out with you
now um i was in this sort of crazy
character mode i felt very awkward
and i was like two different women with
you and neither of them were very
me and so i'm just you know i
at least get to take this opportunity to
uh make it all about you and gush
and love whereas candy and paula were
both these nutty
selfish weirdos you are so brilliant in
this film and yes
you are played two wildly different
characters
in the most extraordinary way and we
spent maybe i think i was there three
days on set maybe and yeah
i don't know how you kept everything
straight how you kept yourself sane
because you're playing
you disappeared into these people and
they're both a little crazy
so anyway both are and i am too so it's
kind of you know
as much as i'm such an optimist we all
have sort of
demons on a dark side and i was like
great i get to purge them in a very
positive cathartic channel
but working with both characters with
you it was amazing as much as i tried to
like
be in the moment and do my job i just
watched you be the
ultimate like scene stealer brilliant
woman that you are and i'm just like god
why i'm working so hard here and she is
just so good
gosh darn it i just want to turn it over
to you and i love that
about women in comedy i feel like we all
support each other and we do a dance we
want to bring something to the table
but we know when to give the platform
shine the light back off and let
everyone shine
and i think about a moment like a film
like bridesmaids where
you all did that so brilliantly with
each other
and i just i mean it's an amazing
balancing act
when you're doing comedies you've got
you know all of these uh the office
uh kimmy schmidt bridesmaids all these
ultimate comedies how do you
share the space and yet shine on your
own
well i think you really latched on to
something i do feel like women
um i i don't want to make any sweeping
generalizations but it
is nice to um boost each other up and so
and in a female ensemble and when it
comes to comedy i do think
yeah everybody wants to shine the light
on someone else and when you work
together in that way it makes the whole
piece
shine a little brighter i also think
have you noticed um
women who are funny i've noticed a lot
and
tina fey said this that um they're
pretty obedient in
in regular life you know pretty um
they're not too wild they follow the
rules and then comedy is sort of their
rebellion and i've sort of noticed that
a lot of the women i've worked with
they're uh they're straight laced in
real life and then they get to have this
outlet like you were talking about kind
of to
be funny and let loose a little bit yeah
i don't relate to that at all but
um but i do like the notion
and i do think that i am
the ultimate sort of i'm always
concerned with
people's comfort and happiness and my
mission in life really is to be good
energy
to other people so where i maybe
should be holding back i'm more
altruistic about caring about everyone
and then i just go bonkers but i do
think that that is an interesting
observation you're talking about you and
tina fey so i believe it and i'll take
[Music]
it